les films d'hollywood aborde souvent le
sujet de la deuxième guerre mondiale et
cette fois ci c'est au tour de george
clooney de s'y frotter avec les
monuments ou un groupe de militaires
temps de sauver de la destruction les
plus grands trésors artistiques de
l'humanité pascal harrison juliet oui
elle est grosse de son histoire
des manières une semaine et d'helmand un
solide qu'elle semble tout droit sorti
de la tête de scénaristes hollywoodiens
pourtant un groupe de militaires formés
d'architectes de conservateurs
d'historiens d'artistes c'est bel et
bien aventuré sur le franc à la fin de
la deuxième guerre mondiale
leur mission empêcher les troupes
d'hitler d'anéantir toutes les oeuvres
d'art qu'elles ont pillé ou quatre coins
de l'europe un fait historique relaté
dans le livre du même nom écrit par
l'américain m et saut
dans son adaptation cinématographique
ces américains anglais français sont
dirigés par georgetown incarné par john
stumme kiko c'est aussi le scénario y
réalise le film
matt damon bernard et john goodman jean
dujardin et quel punch est une
production qui réunit plusieurs gros
canons le scénario fait des monuments
semaine âgée peut entraîner des
militaires improvisé qui pourtant ne
font qu'une bouchée des obstacles sur le
terrain ou presque
histoire ponctuée de petits moments
d'humour et de grandes envolées lyriques
sur l'importance de l'art future
directive
george clooney signe un film
conventionnel qui reste un bon
divertissement mais qui n'est pas un
chef-d'oeuvre
ici pascal harrison juliet radio canada
montréal